families here didn't have time to race
to a communal shelter before the rockets
struck last monday
i keep having flashes that what if the
bomb hit that side
if it hit that side we wouldn't be alive
for sure
do you feel like a little bit calmer
today because there's no siren yeah sure
sure i feel calmer today but i'm
concerned about the future because
today is okay but i have no idea what's
going to happen next year
no one in this jewish neighborhood in
southern israel was killed
but everyone's shaken katya told me how
she
protected her two young daughters yeah
and i was just lying on top of them
a neighbor helped rescue them my
daughter didn't speak
only in the hospital when the
paramedics were treating us that's where
they started to speak a little bit
one floor down more evidence of trauma
the gorensteins were at home when the
blast happened and you can see it
absolutely devastated their apartment
windows smashed in cupboards hanging off
the wall rubble
on the floor and they say well they're
relieved that the ceasefire has been
called like many people here they just
wonder how long it's going to last
the damage here while bad is
incomparable with the scenes in gaza
but this is still a community reeling
the threat of palestinian rocket fire
forced this vet
at a nearby kibbutz to close for the
first time
in years of on off conflict today's her
first day back
she thinks israel's airstrikes were
worthwhile to deter hamas
though she's also no fan of her own
prime minister
i think it's time for him to go it's
been too long already
and i think that we have to have a
change here
we need to be uh we need to do the
change it's enough
lily says the whole country now needs to
mend arabs and jews
it damaged us but it's like a wound and
we will heal and maybe it will make us
stronger
people want to say that we live together
people that
do living in in cooperation and one
want to shout it out and to say there is
a different way we can do it differently
together
and i hope the silent voices will rise
more and more
if not the wounds on both sides will
only worsen
debra haynes sky news ashdod